Hey look here the other ones get all
today I'm in Vegas
[Music]
[Music]
so I'm here with my two hombres Nathan
and Tommy and we're getting ready for
the next leg of our journey so currently
we're in Utah and in a few minutes we're
gonna go pick up a rental car and then
me Mommy and Tommy here are gonna head
off towards Las Vegas and then
eventually to Japan now Tommy do you
know how to say hello in Japanese how do
you say ninja Japanese ninja I wish we
could bring Nathan and Jacob with us to
Japan but Becca's going for a work
conferences she's gonna be in meetings
most the time and having three boys in
Japan it's a little bit much and I miss
my boy we'll be back soon and you're
gonna have fun with Grandma and Grandpa
and cousins and get to do cool stuff
all right guys let's get these bags out
we'll be back
okay little boys it's gonna be hard
leaving these little boys behind I know
my wife's taking it ten times harder
than I am getting you're taking hugs
Oh sounds so good tell me you sad about
Nathan I love you buddy it's gonna be
okay you'll see him we'll get this guy
wisdom okay all right I had to come to
here to the airport to get my rental car
because it's the only place open on
forage
[Music]
there goes a very brave man he's gonna
be babysitting Nathan for like two weeks
hopefully Nathan won't kill him and he'd
been able to unfortunately eat soon
nothing's wrong ordinary you tell me
luck we're in Arizona swear to enforce
forgetting that I'm free of calories
read 107 degrees outside we're in the
desert now [ __ ] match of the surrender
welcome to Nevada
Tommy's a hundred eight degrees outside
hey guys I can see Las Vegas we're
almost here Tommy
man it's been six hours in the car
you've done really well ghetto-fabulous
is probably like the perfect term to
describe Las Vegas
Las Vegas is such a skeezy down though
really it is we're sitting here at an
intersection next to a giant truck with
a billboard full of advertising
strippers so yeah that's that's Las
Vegas in a nutshell some guy took my
bags and I sincerely hope he works for
the hotel otherwise our trip just got
really expensive everything here smells
like baby yeah it's crazy
this place is a madhouse I don't know if
I've ever had to stand in line to check
in before
my clothes hotels got a casino on the
first
or prophecy well guys we're here we're
checked into the cosmopolitan and it's a
bit of a hit in a mess
so on the upside it is a very large
suite reasonably priced for the square
footage and the amenities it's it's not
too bad we've got this hip modern
decorations we've got a crazy awesome
bathroom this is the shower
okay massive shower huge tub with a view
and the view is pretty awesome
we're downtown Las Vegas right in the
strip this is our king bed here a lovely
wife and you step out here onto the
awesome balcony which gives you
incredible view from 18th floor Bellagio
fountain and the strip
however family-friendly this hotel room
is not somebody thought it would be
awesome to decorate the wall with an 8
foot tall naked woman Tommy stop looking
at that
it smells like marijuana and vaping in
here the whole hotel smells like vaping
it's um it's crazy
yeah the beginni ins Bible they have a
book of a collection of ancient japanese
erotica well on the up side of things
grandpa say that nathan is doing great
having a ball which is good that makes
me happy it and you know what we're just
gonna use this as an excuse to take it
easy I think we're just gonna order room
service hanging out in our room watch
some TV with Tommy in the room that
doesn't have a naked little bit on the
wall and just yeah we get a Skype with
Nathan and Jacob we're eating all fancy
pantsy today so I ordered a grilled tea
sandwich and it's got bacon and fig
marmalade on sourdough hmm so this
Suites about $350 a night which is
pretty you know reasonable considering
the size of what you're getting but I'll
tell you the little things like room
service really expensive this is about a
hundred dollar meal for a pizza
it's a penne pasta some cake and and
grilled cheese ham with $95
so yeah they get they gouged the crap
out of you on the extras
Tommy wants the bath so we're gonna fill
up the bathtub for Tommy here and then
you can watch the fireworks how cool is
that give this sit in the massive deep
tub eating pizza watching the fountain
and fireworks on the fourth of July
Tommy you're lucky boy you know that
well it has been a long but relaxing day
I have a lot of activities planned
tomorrow followed by a lot of traveling
to do so we got to get to bed we've
enjoyed watching the fountain and the
fireworks and just relaxing and hanging
out in the room with as a family and
I'll see you guys in the morning all
right guys it's 7:00 in the morning one
of the only places that's open for
breakfast around here is the eggslut so
if you want
omelets or poached eggs or egg
sandwiches something this will work
alright got breakfast for the crew but
it wasn't cheap three egg and bacon
sandwiches three orange juices and three
biscuits with butter sixty dollars this
ain't too bad though eating a fresh roll
with honey butter are the balcony early
in the morning what you talking to me
you talking to me
[Music]
tommy's laughs don't shoot my eye out
like it I'm heading downstairs now I'm
gonna get picked up by a Humvee and go
to a place where I can shoot incredibly
large guns I'm going to Battlefield
Vegas we'd be shooting some guy
My Ride just big deal
holy crap realize that I don't have as
much time as I need to do everything I
want to do holy mackerel
yeah check that out slowly Becker
I want to shoot that displacement it's
if you like guns this is the stuff magic
paraphernalia
RPGs over there so definitely
interesting but I want to check outside
here you know this place actually rents
the tank and for like $3,000 or
something you can rent the tank and then
drive over a car and Tommy would love as
Nathan would love this too but
unfortunately I think you have to be
like 13 or something come here and shoot
so the boys are too young had to leave
them at home these are all the Humvees
they'll come pick you up at your hotel
hey guys check it out I'm in a Huey huh
this is cool you can climb in all this
stuff
yeah you're gonna get a play with all
the little joysticks
even though Tommy and Nathan are too
young to shoot the guns if I hadn't
known they had all this stuff here I
would have brought them just to be able
to play inside that helicopter that's so
cool oh ho ho this is like a legit
Museum here oh yeah well it's a hundred
and eight degrees here in Las Vegas and
as much fun as riding in that Humvee was
I have a new respect for all you guys
who served in Iraq and drove around in
Humvees wearing fatigues and gear in a
hundred plus degrees I was sweating it
out in just my t-shirt so thank you for
your service by the way I can hear a
speaker there they're playing chatter
between ground forces and aerial forces
in combat it's kind of nice guy you come
in and check in guys get all your guns
and ammo ready and then they paid you
with this little thingamajiggy when
you're ready and you can just take out
all the tanks and everything while you
wait all right guys it's go time
[Music]
[Music]
to fire semi and all very light recoil
you can switch it to full auto whenever
you're ready to okay simple school is
kind of a short stock so you gotta tuck
it in
yeah that's kind of fun that's pretty
cool yeah pretty fun little gun yeah
yeah that is that is fun so f2000 of
course this is a five five six rifle
they're gonna have full control over the
automatic and semi-automatic in the
trigger so single all the way back for
auto interested it's a two-stage trigger
that is hard to control it catches you
off-guard doesn't matter yeah it's ended
up Oh too much fun guys
this is this is like a buffet of
ammunition oh is this what they call a
saw like the squad operated weapon kind
of thing that is a lot easier to keep on
target that thing doesn't twit I've kind
of forgotten what I ordered so the fact
he's pulling out these large pieces of
metal is very ominous well I got a
feeling we're gonna be using I used a
little peep sight okay
front sight hard upward squeeze on that
trigger okay
3:30 out 6:30 at 6:00 holy mackerel shot
a bolt-action 30-odd six this is gonna
be way better
that is one of my favorite weapons here
yeah figure the recoil springs about
that long barrel reciprocate and they
comp since all that pressure ups that's
that's nice I I felt that my my forehead
eyes if you don't have a fantasy about
shooting a minigun you're not into guns
that's just how it is this is gonna be
awesome
three two one
I knew it's gonna be cool that was
cooler than I thought
yeah I actually hit something oh yeah
yeah a gut shot him but it'll do the job
quantity not quality that's right what
that is right there look at that so
we're gonna go do the vault - holy
mackerel look at that that smells manly
so what's your favorite gun what's
what's your favorite my all-time
favorite is the m1 garand the m14 it's a
good dirty gun right there's old fast
World War two it's the one that you see
in the movies where the clip pops up
yeah once you're done love it yeah
that's cool even have the golden a K if
you're into James Bond Goldeneye there
Hello Kitty ak-47 awesome boy is that
beast oh man
oh that's anti I almost got that well
that's the anti-tank one right the lobby
Oh virginal chamber in 20 millimeter
ours is chambered in 50 yeah I just
finished my rounds this is awesome guys
these H case yep I don't know a lot I've
recognized again everyone and you know
wine pigs and acorns and everything
please look at this this is just pistols
holy mackerel
and just a casual it was that fifty
callus yeah the m2g that's what the goes
on top of the Humvees right yeah so it's
like the 1919 you fired just much much
bigger much much bigger geez and then an
RPG you see dummy ground I assume about
to say that looked like a nerf blaster
but that's a that's an automatic shotgun
isn't it semi-auto that's a grenade
launcher right yeah sure that's cool so
what did the dummy rounds do they just
bounced off the wall or indoors we shoot
it's basically a shotgun shell similar
guys definitely you got to check out
battlefield Vegas if you have two
minutes to rub together in Las Vegas
check this place out I'll put a link in
the description to their details and
their website this is a pretty
affordable way to fulfill your bucket
list that was awesome
I got a grin plastered from ear to ear
bed that was cool that was cool pretty
affordable I mean if you just want to
try out a gun you can try a lot of
different guns for a pretty reasonable
price
picking up to the hotel to drop it off
at my hotel like an hour 45 minutes so
he only got a few minutes to squeeze and
here in Las Vegas does have Battlefield
Vegas come pick you up yeah so the guy
over my shoulder he's smoking weed on
the street yeah he's got a joint right
there that's Vegas for you drag my son
two blocks through the heat to go do go
to a restaurant where they have like a
eating challenge place is closed oh well
just a nice walk I guess yeah it's close
I'm kind of looking forward to leaving
Vegas how about you Luke yeah I'm done
we're getting close you ready to race so
I'm really excited for this Becca's
gonna get a drive a racecar but the
funny part about this whole thing is six
months ago my dear sweet wife suffered a
serious nerve injury giving birth to our
youngest child because of that she has
not been allowed to drive for six months
like a week ago she went and did like a
little test drive with our minivan to
kind of see if she was good to go this
will be your real your first real
driving experience in six months won't
it yeah way to jump in the deep end of
the pool baby y'all just go check it out
the Dodge Charger Hellcat I believe I
actually really wanted to drive one of
these things but there's no way I'm
fitting inside all I ever you pull look
at this this car doesn't even come up to
my waist down
hey Tommy what do you think is that
pretty cool
[Music]
[Music]
couple Ferraris oh look another Ferrari
so we'll go do a couple laps around
watch red drive drive same back now the
name of the game is you're driving
around is aim for the green coat too
slow in did you like it shoulder okay
hey daddy a good look at that look at
that race car fancy Becky you're making
helmet so sexy right now and me and
Tommy will be up on the observation deck
I'm her entourage let's go
you giving mommy some last-minute
coaching remember Becca remember
everything we learned from watching
Ricky Bobby just go like the wind
now we're not allowed to videotape
inside the car they've got cameras of
their own in there but me and Tommy can
go up to the observation deck here watch
mama go around the track here I'm so
glad to see her doing this I was so
worried she wouldn't be able to get
behind the wheel you know it doesn't
matter how fast she goes as long as
she's having fun I think she's having a
ball there's there's mommy in the white
car Tommy
[Music]
[Laughter]
there there's mom a good adorable slow
white speck in the horizon
[Music]
[Music]
holy mackerel
[Music]
there you go awesome
be true
what to think Becca that allows the fun
you look great out there babe did he see
Tommy cheering yeah you jump up and down
screaming go mama go
you look great Becca
[Music]
I like being a fast woman
oh that looks a lot faster hey Tommy is
mommy going fast you guys have a good
time all right well we need to get head
into Los Angeles we got a plane to catch
Las Vegas is a hot place but it is a dry
heat dry burning searing withering heat
great Tommy do you have a good time in
that Porsche well let's get the air
conditioning on and welcome to
California we're here
look at those solar farms way out
there's a lot of a desert tom
here we are in Baker California in the
Mojave Desert and it is a hundred and
nine degrees outside let's go outside
pump some gas we just drove past the
world's tallest thermometer
unfortunately it's a rectal one here we
are entering the Republic of California
and we have to go through customs and
immigration here well we'll just customs
there's a crazy fire over there five
hours later we're in LA baby alright go
get checked in
forget Weezer forget toto we Tommy
[Music]
well you got water mm-hmm I was a [ __ ]
down there
[Music]
come on let's go all right over here any
hotel that has carp swimming in it is a
good hotel so we've picked an excellent
spot guys I am so tired but it feels so
good just to sit down
and and not have to drive anywhere to do
it so full of food all right Tommy this
gets you ready for bed bud if you liked
this video don't forget to click
Subscribe because we got many more great
videos coming up and if you want to see
part three of our 2018 world tour where
we go to Kyoto Japan check the link in
the description we put out new videos
every Saturday morning and we've got
lots of great adventures coming up so
don't forget to click Subscribe thanks
for watching